hey guys
i thought i'd post a quick update on our
hail lobster merch and the whole red
skull fiasco watch the video linked to
get information about what happened if
you don't know about it already long
story short my dad was written into a
marvel comic as a super nazi villain and
we turned it around made merch
even though it was kind of stressful at
the time and have been donating 100 of
the proceeds to charity
dad wanted to donate the money to two
charities aimed at helping families and
children specifically we chose one
charity based in the states called boys
and girls clubs of america i just had a
call with someone from there who's
amazing super thankful and a pleasure to
work with they're doing fantastic things
the other charity was one near toronto
that is affiliated with the university
of toronto where my dad taught a charity
for children and families we thought it
was a good idea because they purport to
support kids and families going through
mental health problems a very noble
cause
they have tweets asking the ontario
government for money to donate
when we chose the charities my dad goes
do we have to be worried about more
controversy what if they don't take the
money and i said why would a charity not
accept money we don't have to worry
about that dad
and we just got the money we donated
back from the canadian charity seventy
thousand dollars and the executive
chairman of the charity asked us to
scrub their name from our socials the
charity associated with u of t
gave back 70 000 worth of donations
donated from a u of t professor you
cannot make this stuff up
i wanted to make this video because
it was a bit upsetting i can't believe
how horrible of an individual you have
to be to give back money aimed at
helping children because of your
ideological beliefs or how
confused you have to be i guess
i guess they're more concerned about
politics than using money to help the
mental health of children
interesting seventy thousand dollars
canadian wasn't donated to a charity
because they didn't want to be
associated with jordan peterson more
than they wanted money to help kids
fortunately that's a super easy way to
clear out the political ideologues that
are saying they're in it for the
children but really they're in it
because it makes them look good
this doesn't look good guys
however it worked out in the end i found
this amazing company that makes off-road
wheelchairs
for people who need wheelchairs called
not a wheelchair they're linked below
the wheelchairs they make can go on sand
and on the grass and over rough terrain
and they actually look like a lot of fun
we've fully paid for five of those
wheelchairs and for the next 25 or 30
people they get a thousand dollars off
of their wheelchairs 100 of the proceeds
we donate are going directly towards
people who want these wheelchairs the
people i've spoken with at that company
were awesome if you guys want to support
this
these t-shirts
there you go
full view
they're still available t-shirts and
posters they won't be available for more
than the next couple of weeks in this
style
thanks to everyone who did support us if
you want to stay updated on podcasts and
seriously random things that seem to
happen hit subscribe these shirts are
limited edition and won't be available
in this format for long the money is
going to continue to go to the charities
that were awesome also to make matters
more hilarious
i bought 20 of the comics and had dads
sign them
these limited edition comics are
available for 250 each
because i'm a greedy capitalist
take that tanahisi coats
and i'm keeping five of them just
because who knows when these will come
in handy in the future so there are 15
available you can email red skull at
if you're interested in buying one of
these hilarious items
signed
i worked with our team and designed the
shirts
and bought the comics
so if anyone's gonna have a little flip
out for the comics in the merch that's
on me with sign off from jbp because why
not have to have a sense of humor to be
able to handle how weird the world is
thanks guys i hope you i hope you found
this entertaining